[Music]
say hello to our special celebrity
correspondent when we pick the absolute
perfect person to talk back Shepard
about his new movie chips is why hi I'm
Kristen Bell interviewing for
Entertainment Tonight I have with me the
lovely and beautiful remind me of your
name again Mike Mike Mike shepherd
Mike Steve James - back chef Jack
Shepherd that was it and Michael Payne
yeah Michael lovely and he'll send you
mine and you guys are enough your
Christian Bale Christian Bale yeah and
we're all called chips what's up I'm
John poncherello inspired by the classic
TV series Dax wrote and directed the
action comedy where he and Pena try to
uncover some crooked cops in the
California Highway Patrol along the way
there are shootouts motorcycle stunts
and explosions galore
this is like they wouldn't Harry Met
Sally with motorcycles it's Harry yes
can I say you gave me the best
compliment we've had which is she hates
motorcycles could care less she saw the
movie for the first time she goes I got
to tell you what you pulled off a
miracle I actually cared about the
motorcycle chases guys guys guys that
was spectacular
Kristin plies Dax his ex-wife who he's
trying to win back what are you wearing
oh it's my um my uniform from the CHP
you almost didn't cast me Dax can you
explain this here to comment yeah you
are on a cellular level likeable it's
nauseating in fact it's hard to stand
next to you in this role that you took
on is is a terrible unlikable jerk of a
woman and I obviously did not think of
you for that and then you read it and
then you said I will be playing this
role and then I said and you are the
boss what was your favorite part about
directing me Dax or the worst part about
directing me there is no worst part
about directing you the best part about
directing you is that you're perfect on
take one every time what was your
favorite part about shooting this movie
everything was good yeah me we've been
we've done a bunch of movies you know
like a lot of times you just don't like
doing that movie or those people but
this one was a great time 45 days of
like just fun
so Thank You Dax and Michael for making
the first ever a ladies motorcycle movie
chips March 24th be there or be square
[Music]